well if you are facing problems due to
the covet pandemic
clark county wants to help county and
city leaders holding a virtual town hall
where the main message was take control
of the situation
christian casares joining us live in
studio to break it down
and to help keep you in your home that's
right brian well local leaders insisted
that the tenant must take action and
take control
of the situation otherwise it's almost
guarantee the eviction
will occur now the purpose of the
virtual town hall wednesday
was to inform the community in both
english and spanish about their options
or two
two weeks before both state and federal
eviction moratoriums expire
now county leaders say if you receive an
eviction notice very important
because of covet 19 your first step is
to file a response
in person at the courthouse or online
remember there is also
rental assistance through the cares
housing assistance program or chaps
as it's known the legal aid center of
southern nevada says nothing will
legally avoid
any eviction but it doesn't hurt to try
every step along the way it could
potentially help you before the
eviction's even filed
it could potentially help you negotiate
with your landlord if your landlord
knows
that you have an application pending
perhaps your landlord will not even
initiate the eviction process
in mediation could it help you yes
well county leaders say about 12
thousand folks applied for the chat
program in december
and about 9 000 more have submitted an
application president biden's american
rescue plan
will allocate more funding to help
people facing evictions because of the
pandemic
again local leaders keep stressing to
the community to apply now if you need
assistance once the president's aid is
approved the county
expects a flood of applicants and that
could obviously delay
your submission we have more information
on our website eightnewsnow.com
questioncasters8 news now